MALE SPEAKER: Really
good really good.
Yeah.
Very, very excited.
I have like three
most useful things,
so I don't know
what that counts as.
But I think you have first
thing you have preparation.
I learned a lot about
the preparation process
in the video, which I previously
didn't actually consider.
I used to think of people
with their shaky cameras.
Then actually have an idea
of what they're doing.
But most of the time they
probably had a storyboard.
And it's not like by accident.
And then eventually it
becomes the idea of iteration.
So you have to keep
trying different scenes.
Many, many takes.
It never came to my mind.
And lastly, you have to
have the passion for this.
Because you would
do a lot of takes.
You will be pretty
sleepy after a while,
but you love what you've done.
And I'm kind of excited
to show what I have.
I guess the hardest part
is there's so much content,
and there's a lot of
technical stuff there.
I wish I knew more
about the Creative Suite
and the software.
So I guess I was limited
in that department.
But other than that, I think
the preparation part gives me
the background.
It helps me to do a lot
of different things.
Yeah.
Thank you.